seriously who else but James Bond could
step into the role of Indiana Jones's
father well only eats he has Harrison
Ford and Sean Connery breaking down how
they created their unforgettable
on-screen dynamic well he's a very good
actor Harrison Ford probably better I'm
his dad well I was pleased to do it I
mean when we finally found something
that we all were excited about we being
Stephen than George and I got to be real
exciting actually when we got thinking
about the cast a very wise idea to bring
Sean into the end of the formula I was
anxious to work with him at just as
another actor there's some physical
similarities of similarities in style
and attitude of Sean and I that I think
worked well for the characters
which originally Spielberg's idea that I
actually played a father but one wanted
to get as much aggression as possible
more of a sort of European concept of a
father and Victorian not so
understanding where their children his
Americans are you left just when you
were becoming interesting I love it when
he calls him junior it's just so no dad
Junior
don't call me junior you begin to
understand why he's the boy he is
I could you see him as a boy in the
movie and then you see him as years of
Indiana Jones well there's a
vulnerability that everyone has with
their father that it's it's unlike a
vulnerability that you have with
everybody else and I think it's a part
of everybody's experience there's a ring
of a real ring of truth to the
relationship between Indiana Jones and
his father I just wasn't ready Marcus
five minutes would have been enough and
this kind of father it starts to explain
a lot of things equally when they have
the problem when the father thinks that
he's lost him like most people it was
rather too late he thinks realizes my
god I really had a lot of things I
should have said I would not have been
pleased to do it if we hadn't been able
to expose a side of Indiana's
personality that we hadn't seen before
some more depth of character I thought
was necessary and we and we got it in
spades I think that's his name Henry
Jones jr. like Indiana we named the dog
Indiana but equally going along that
they become almost like a team
so it's scored on all the points I think
which gives it a bit of a zzzz at the
end you know when they're all kind of
riding off into the sunset night after
the grail sequence after you Junior
[Applause]
how do you explain this guy's appeal
he's not standard here oh he's not
standard leading man
good-looking some visionary movies are
very successful the movies III mean I'm
not talking about their financial
success I'm saying as movies they are
very successful movies that's why that's
why they that's why we we like them
because they work as movies and we like
movies
[Music]